my name is rod Emery I've been in the
Porsche restoration business my entire
life
we're in my shop and North Hollywood
this is what I love to do I love to take
these cars and give them a new life
I come from a family that's been
building custom cars dating back into
the 40s my grandfather had a shop about
a mile from here in Burbank from 1948 to
1962 he was really one of the early
pioneers and customizers any taught me
how to actually use real tools and
taught me how to gas weld and how to
shape metal and that led to me doing my
first porsche restoration when i was 14
years old the people that come to me are
the guys that love that classic shape
and design of a Porsche 356 or in early
911 but they want it personalized and
they want it to have more power and more
performance when Porsche was first
building their early aluminum bodied
cars they were taking parts and
components from Volkswagen but then they
built their own chassis in their own
aluminum body they would take a standard
356 and they drill holes in it and put
hood straps they'd put fog lights on and
they'd put a bigger engine so even
though there's people out there that'll
say oh how could you customize these
cars
how could you change the characteristics
of them but I'm only doing what Portia
designed these cars to do and that's to
have fun with them personalize them and
I'll do things like rolling the doors
and rockers all the way into the floor
to give the body a little bit thinner
side view I'll change the a and B
pillars in the car to give the roof a
little bit different style or design
very subtle changes that I do to the car
sometimes but they're all things that
take a tremendous amount of work to
accomplish once we have the car in our
possession and it shipped here to the
shop the first thing the guys and I do
is we put it up on the lift
then we evaluate the car make sure that
it has the components and everything
that we need and then we disassemble a
car this is a 1960 B coupe it's got a
very minimal rust and it's just a good
one to build on
after we disassembled the car the next
step is to get all of the paint and
undercoating off of them so we send the
actual chassis or the tub of the car to
a place that has a large media blast
room that they can blast the paint on
but all the smaller parts bumpers
smaller components we use our in-house
media blast cabinet that allows us to
put the part inside and then we can
blast either sand glass bead plastic or
walnut shells to remove all the paint
and material off now the next phase of
the project is to get it in our metal
shop and start doing all the rust repair
and fabrication right now we build
approximately six or seven cars a year
and it's a combination of restoration
parts
and parts that are either remanufactured
or new original Porsche parts but then
everything that's modified on these cars
we have to build in-house we created a
wood buck to be able to give us the
shapes of a 356 that we're working on
and so once we have the shape done in
wood then the next step is to make a
template or a pattern so that we can do
the initial cut of the aluminum this
piece of equipment that I'm using right
now is called an English wheel and it's
used to be able to put curves in sheet
metal or aluminum the bulk of our
equipment that we use is all 40s 50s and
60s era equipment to do the metal
shaping and fabrication this eckle is
from the 1960s with a combination of you
know newer technology even 3d scanners
that we use to do some recreation of
parts you just have a really nice blend
of equipment and we take great pride in
our tools because that's really what
helps us create these cars after the car
is gone through its metalworking phase
it goes through the body and paint phase
of the project when you're doing the
final bodywork on these cars you don't
want to over sand an area you really
just have to continue to make that shape
smooth
it really is about flowing with the
lines of the car and finessing it while
we were doing the metalwork body and
paint all of the components and parts
were all being prepared so engine was
being built transmission was being built
hardware was being plated so once we get
to the assembly phase of the car we
start putting all the pieces on it
that's really everyone's favorite part
because that's when the car really
starts to take shape once it's assembled
that's when the real fun starts because
that's when we get to turn the key and
take it out on the road
it looks like this you know amazing
little vintage car when you get behind
the wheel and you start driving it you
realize that it has the heart and soul
of the early 356
you see that sound and it still has that
you know that little bit of vibration
and feel even smell of an early portion
has the performance and drivability of a
newer Porsche they're just amazing to
drive
we always put a couple hundred miles on
the cars before we deliver it to the
customer
we just want to make sure that the
engine is broken in make sure that the
car has had all of the necessary
adjustments everything from the
suspension - you know carburetors being
perfect and you know that we made sure
that that door shuts perfectly and that
the window rolls up and that there are
air leaks then once we're comfortable we
know that everything's ready on the car
then we move on to delivery people often
ask me you know do you find this type of
work art and I really do I take metal
and these cars and rearrange things then
I guess technically I am an artist
creating rolling art
I love what I do and I get to wake up
every morning and just create and build
amazing cars